in every story there is a hero in a
villain in your story you're both all
the bright aspects and all the dark
aspects of yourself orchestrate the
melody of your song a song that you need
to hear first before anyone else but in
order to hear it you have to learn to
listen to listen not only to what you
want but also to what you're afraid of
your fears and your darkness are in the
dust from you do notice true them face
them analyze them internalize them the
shadow is always there and will always
be but the shadow can look big or it can
look small depending on the angle from
which the light caresses you what is the
size of your shadow Carl Gustav Jung was
one of the most important psychologists
of the previous century he's also one of
my biggest influencers since he's one of
the few that have attempted to bridge
the notions of psychology and
spirituality in an effort to discover
ways to transcend the human condition
Jung has travelled a lot to India and
immerse himself in different spiritual
practices his work was constantly
evolving and it was this evolution that
produced comprehensive analysis of
concepts like the ego the shadow the
archetypes and the anima and animus
especially the shadow has always been
intriguing topic among people and with
regards to it Jung has stated the shadow
is a moral problem that challenges the
whole ego personality for no one can
become conscious of the shadow with her
considerable moral effort to become
conscious of it involves recognizing the
dark aspects of the personality as
present and real this act is the
essential condition for any kind of
self-knowledge the use of the word
shadow wasn't chosen unintentionally
Jung was always good at portraying
complex ideas in a syllable visual
manner he used mental imagery in order
to create anchors with concepts already
familiar to human cognition the shadow
is dark and elusive it is impossible to
catch its size can alter depending on
your position in space and these
ubiquitous whenever light is present
there you go one can form a somewhat
basic understanding of the
concept without the need to delve into
arcane terms another crucial thing to
ponder is that the shadow itself due to
the darkness that it forms and due to
the distance that it creates from a
physical body of a person becomes
something not so many people are eager
to confront and this is one of the major
ideas associated with a union shadow
although we usually see the shadow as an
integral part of our existence most of
us are willfully blind to this existence
our dark side is concealed or
camouflaged in painful attempt to
protect an image that fits a narrative
that we decide to espouse through social
conditioning we come to construct the
facade that can keep the substrate of
our constructed identity stable so that
we can keep feeling safe safety however
is ill-defined in that space we inhabit
how can one feel safe when there is so
much unknown territory out there that
cannot any given point in time
convulsive foundations of our fragile
Constitution the person is as free as a
minor louse and if the mind creates
barriers between the reality of the
person and the reality of the rest of
the world delusion and neuroses could
take over when you see people operate in
a state of enforced ignorance that
attempts to preserve a certain status
quo then the shadow can only grow bigger
and forced ignorance and titles the
shadow would take over since the
individual is incapable of controlling
it because he or she is not even aware
of its existence we can control what we
don't understand every aspect of one's
unconscious identity the cannot
metamorphose into conscious judgment
will perpetually impede one's progress
for its creating a fantastic world that
cannot synchronize with the frequencies
of the real world in such a landscape
the real world or at least whatever we
can understand of it becomes an
egotistical battleground that leads to
collision and madness that is not how
our perception should meet the world
should be a forum for dialogue and
constant experimentation while we strive
to define the moral imperatives that
could alleviate or suffering everything
beyond that should be viewed with
skepticism if that seems poignant to
some
that is clearly because the shadow
element hasn't been dealt with
effectively
this includes animalistic needs
primitive instincts sexual desires
traumatic experiences and also positive
aspects of one's character that may also
remain hidden in one Shadow regardless
of the idea Socratic nature of one
Shadow the process of assimilation has
always been universal and it is
represented by the following sequence
evidently assimilation can't occur if
the stages of encounter and merger don't
take place first there's certainly a
heroic act for the angst entail and the
process is immense there's nothing
scarier than facing the deepest realms
of ourself but there is also nothing
more rewarding than that assimilation is
a lengthy process that mans mainly
psychotherapy but also hours of
introspection and concentrate valuation
and recalibration of personal behaviors
and beliefs our cerebral makeup is quite
plastic but its plasticity is predicated
upon our ability to sew kiss discipline
and tenacity we can just expect the
divine force to rescue us from our
suffering with our only chance for
redemption and catharsis the shadow has
a challenging nature therefore the
process of assimilation requires one to
ask oneself some challenging questions
most of you have heard of the story of
dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
the infamous phrase is inspired by the
book Strange Case of dr. Jekyll and mr.
Hyde written by this car is all for a
Robert Louis Stevenson in 1886 in it he
describes the life a man who transforms
between two personî
dr. Henry Jekyll and mr. Edward Hyde the
story was so powerful and it resonated
with so many people that entered the
vernacular and whenever we encounter
characters with an unpredictably dual
nature we almost immediately recall the
story of dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
most of us can cite events from our
lives where our actions and our intent
didn't really align we behaved as if we
were different people that's a result of
a plethora of factors that can affect
our behavior and can result in lack of
congruence in what we think feel and do
social conditioning latent desires
mental fatigue and many more reasons can
come to mind the truth however is that
our ability to fight them is within our
control there are times in my life where
I feel that I will go crazy to you to
over analysis of certain happenstance is
my paradigm I'm not sure how to deal
with specific scenarios and more often
than not I tend to question the reality
of those scenarios my perception might
be prone to certain biases and
prejudices and cloud my judgment so I
tend to question the basis of every
claim that I make despite how awkward
this process might seem it is a process
that can yield tremendous benefits in
one's journey to assimilate the shadow
your shadow due to its dark nature is
constantly forming a cloud over your
judgment this cloud can never disappear
but it can certainly update through
meticulous introspection and cultivation
of wisdom by some strange technological
and philosophical osmosis we can create
a universal moral framework that can we
accept it by every soul on this planet
this might sound ambitious but trust me
it's not humans have always found ways
to coexist and respect each other
because the notion of coexistence is
central to our survival our revolution
has created countless iterations of our
species but our bedrock is more or less
the same what does not allow us to
behave constantly in a respectful and
mutually beneficial way is the shadow
when the shadow takes over any
discussion for a universal moral
framework cannot find fruitful ground
we negotiate and debate and exchange
verbal tantrums in an attempt to defend
our point of view in our position in the
dominance hierarchy of society some
people do that in a more ethical way and
in order to defend goodness but most
just keep perpetuating banal attitudes
and approaches and it is this banality
in trivialities existence that needs to
be dealt with in order to identify what
is morally good actually it is the
combination of that and the ability to
showcase common sense in the face of
trivial matters with common sense the
discovery of a solution to most of our
problems could be accelerated
dramatically life might be in
amalgamation of complex instances but
our cognitive apparatus is more than
capable of making sense of them all it
takes is to offer clarity to our
judgement and common sense is the
imperative in that respect especially
when it comes to orienting ourselves
towards what is morally good dr. jordan
peterson likes to promulgate that life
is struggle and that unless you don't
voluntarily accept this as a fact
struggle will keep manifesting itself in
every facet of your existence life is
suffering right indisputable what do you
do about that you you voluntarily accept
it and then strive to overcome the
suffering that's a consequence of that I
like this idea a lot because it reminds
me how important clarity is when it
comes to the betterment of our living
conditions in order to ameliorate them
something you need to understand its
mechanics may be something isn't working
well because a part that comprises the
hole is actually malfunctioning when we
break down the hole in parts and
fastidiously examine these parts we can
discover details about systems that are
usually obscure then we can go back to
the system itself and look at how what
we discovered can improve the
performance of the system as a whole the
bottom-up approach is always more
effective and usually more meritocratic
thus empowering the parts to work
synergistically for a common cause
clarity manifests itself that way when
you allow the park to discover its
nuances and all its capabilities you end
up with a reinforced version of it that
can offer more to the whole humans
operate like that and the dawn of the
internet made that idea more vivid we
experience a collective awakening that
can perhaps lead to a collective
enlightenment information becomes widely
accessible and we can improve our error
correcting mechanisms just by asking and
gathering as many views as possible that
right here is the essence of clarity and
its only obstacle is the shadow a person
who clings to outdated and ill-defined
views will only reinforce the shadow and
stagnate in a swamp of confusion
incessant knowledge seeking is the name
of the game a game we should all prepare
to play I want to conclude this video
essay with a passage from the red book
probably Carl Jung's most important work
be silent and listen have you recognized
your madness and do you admit it have
you noticed that all your foundations
are completely mired in madness do you
not want to recognize your madness and
welcome it in a friendly manner you want
it to accept everything so except
madness to let the light of your madness
shine until it will suddenly Donnell you
madness is not to be despised and not to
be feared but instead you should give it
life if you want to find paths you
should also not spurn madness since it
makes up such a great part of your
nature be glad that you can recognize it
for you will thus avoid becoming its
victim madness is a special form of the
spirit and and clinks to all teachings
and philosophies but even more to a
daily life since life itself is full of
craziness and at bottom utterly
illogical man strives to work reason
only so that he can make rules for
himself life itself has no rules there
is its mystery and it's unknown law what
you call knowledge is an attempt to
impose something comprehensible on life
there is not much to say after you read
those words only that there is so much
madness in life but there is also so
much truth in madness hi everyone the
creation of this video allowed me to
express myself in a way that illuminates
the struggles of my inner world and I
truly believe that most of you could
resonate with my views asking yourself
questions like how often do I question
the nature of my reality or how do I
orient myself towards what is morally
good or how do I offer a clarity to
every facet of my existence it's
definitely a strenuous act but also a
rewarding one as a huge thank you for
making it to the end of this video and
for supporting my work I would like to
create my first giveaway
I will send a copy of the red book
Young's most celebrated work to one of
you
all you need to do is follow me on
instagram subscribe to this channel and
get notifications and message me on
instagram confirming that you did all
that i will randomly pick the winner in
a week from now and i will contact you
in your Instagram account so stay tuned
again thanks for watching see you in the
next video
[Music]
you